[Music]
hi my name is John Sculley my friends
call me Scully this my wife Maddy we're
from San Antonio Texas coming together
as a family a big blended family it was
a lot of stress like most people we
married because you know because of
chemistry not because we kind of vetted
each other and decided we're you know
were functional people but she was 37
and I was 38 19 I had three kids from
the prior marriage she had to she'd been
a single mom for nine years or so and
always really struggled with money and
my assumption is she's struggling
because it's single mom two kids I'd
also been in domestic violence
situations where they controlled all of
the money so I had that that I didn't
want to let him know about my money or
anything about it because I didn't want
him to take control of it but she had a
lot of debt and we came together with
with all of these kids and all of the
stress under one roof and we didn't
combine our finances you know I kind of
paid the mortgage and the car payments
and she'd pay the utilities and in 2009
I had an opportunity to get him get a
master's degree and we just didn't even
see each other she she spent her time
with our daughter and I'm just working
and going to school and and art and
we're just living completely almost
completely separate lives
we were talking we come in the house and
go separate directions I'm not sure what
compelled me to do it but I happened to
check my credit at some point and I
pulled my credit report and there was
like $20,000 in credit card debt that
was in my name that I had no idea I had
so I find out about it right and you
know we have kind of that come-to-jesus
conversation and we talked through it
and you know and I paid it off
I was broken and I thought as long as I
look perfect on the outside but I was I
was ruining our house and our family and
our marriage I was just crazy proverbs
25 28 says a person without self-control
is like a city with broken down walls
and I had no control over my anger my
emotions my spending anything my words I
was mean I you know I was just an ugly
person few more years go by and we hit a
breaking point in their relationship
where I just saw no hope scared to death
you know what what that meant to our
daughter I finally gave up and hired an
attorney and file for divorce and and I
left
[Music]
we met together at some you know kind of
mandatory counseling thing I think and
somehow we walked out of the place
different doors or something and we met
on on the stairs or something outside of
this counselor's office and that was a
that was a bit of a turning point in our
relationship
we knew we loved each other we were like
we don't want to be doing that so we
started counseling in April of 2012 a
friend of mine asked me if I wanted to
go see Dave Ramsey at a live event here
in San Antonio and it was the most
amazing experience it she said that that
line that he says if you have problem
with your money it's not the money it's
a person in the mirror and right there
it just clicked I was the problem it
gave me hope that I could change the
person in the mirror and that we could
get together on our finances and we
could still still you know make our
marriage work I knew I could do this and
all I had to do was convince him
ask him can we do this you know can we
try this please and really you didn't
trust me talk is cheap right actions
speak much louder than words and by this
time we're starting to go to a local
church lo and behold our our church
offers Financial Peace University so
simultaneously we signed up for a
marriage recovery class and for FPU and
it just gave us a lot of tools to to
really diffuse these these difficult
situations that all couples go through
for us were buried in over $300,000 in
debt when we went through that class and
what I saw and Maddy was this incredible
energy to do whatever it takes to get
out of debt she's we sold everything
that wasn't nailed down in our home what
what you can accomplish when both both
of you are kind of pulling in the same
direction with your finances is is it's
powerful
for us it's a complete paradigm shift
from what's going on in American culture
right people want instant gratification
we've completely flipped that based on
you know these principles and you know
that first 15 months or so we paid off
almost 110,000 dollars in debt
August 18th we've had off the house this
this past summer we've gone to Nashville
and we're pacing the floor that morning
ready to go do our debt-free screen
we've been investing ever since we paid
off all the consumer debt and in the
land that we had it's not even
mathematically possible we had grown our
our investments by nearly 900,000 eight
hundred sixty thousand dollars net worth
is in the neighborhood of 1.3 million
dollars as we stood up to do our
debt-free screen and that's the house
and investments retirement accounts
okay so you want to get a divorce so
eight million weeks you know those go to
this class sit down and dream about what
if we didn't have any debt you know what
if we could live what if we could do
whatever we wanted to do dream about
that and then make a commitment for nine
more weeks let's just go to this class
and if it doesn't work okay it doesn't
work probably will but when you can come
home and have a conversation with your
spouse about finances when you never
could before and it's not an argument
it's not scary anymore and it's bringing
you closer together
there's a lot of folks that have really
good incomes and they're just
disorganized can work together and kind
of harness the power of these principles
you can you can turn your life around in
a short period of time and those days
when you're struggling and when you're
tired of paying off debt and you don't
want to do it anymore okay so but what
we used to do is we go to this
restaurant my Donuts you buy one mail
you get one free so we put those in the
freezer so we'd had a romantic meal I'd
light a candle we preheat the Italian
food put it on nice plates and then we'd
like move the table and we'd dance in
the kitchen and just reconnect remember
why you're doing it and then okay I can
do this for five years or I can do this
for however long it's gonna take cuz
then once you're finished your life is
just that weight is lifted off your
shoulders and you're free you're really
free
individually my turning point was when I
went to see Dave I think as a couple our
turning point was when we came out of
that attorney's office and we met at the
stairs and we just knew we got something
here and we don't want to let it go you
know God had a different plan for us
the debt-free
[Music]
you know we started out all this
chemistry came together in this marriage
in really walked away from God and you
know as a family and we got ourselves in
a gigantic pile of debt we nearly lost
everything you know another broken
marriage for both of us and a child that
you know wouldn't have both parents so
in five years we look back and we've
paid off over $300,000 in debt and now
in net worth at one point almost 1.3
million and saved the marriage which was
really the goal right bonus bonus from
God
[Music]
you